I don't know if there's a strategy maybe
to
figure out more quickly if someone's not
right for you rather than waiting that
full one and a half to two year period
yeah I think
um there's some obvious signs where
you're really gonna like destroy your
life pretty badly if you get involved
with a gal so
um a woman that's violent you know for
example would be a you know good example
that's one of the red flags so
um I've dealt with guys that have gotten
married to women or lived with women uh
you know just because they love bomb a
lot of times they're pretty crazy too
you know so it's you know it's so it's a
whole confusing crazy for for love
um you know they'll throw things at them
they've thrown knives at them they've
been stabbed with forks
um if a woman demonstrates that she's
violent to any degree to you you should
get rid of her quickly like it's it's
not even an option to to date her it's
like
even even becoming friends with benefits
or any of these like short-term like
arms length sort of relationships is a
bad idea because if he doesn't get her
away and she throws one of her Hissy
Fits and becomes violent uh you know the
cops show up it's it's probably not her
that's going to be hauled away and Cuffs
in the back of the cruise room to spend
the night in the Slimer it's probably
going to be you
um and there's men that I know that have
lost their opportunity to graduate as a
licensed Medical Professional because of
because they invited a violent woman
into their life in a relationship
um and they were suspended from school
and were unable to complete because of
the charges or uh you know guys that
were educational
um you know professionals and they got
thrown out of the school system because
of a false domestic violence charge I
mean if you're around children all day
and a woman claims that you're uh
violent you know uh unjustly you know
makes it up then you've lost your job
right so there's lots of areas where a
bright red flag should definitely not be
ignored I think most of these you should
pay attention to and you should only
Overlook if she's working on them you
know for example
um let's use uh you know a woman that's
got like an addictive you know
personality
um I've dated a woman at one point Who
Loved going shopping for things and
would bring them home and to try them
out and you know return them it was an
uncommon for her to be like oh I just
bought these seven lamps to test them
out by the nightstand and I want to see
which one looks best and I'm going to
bring six of them back and it's like
okay you've got a shopping addiction
like this is a little bit of a problem
if you're spending your entire week
spare time out of work in the return
line at customer service to bring [__]
back that you didn't like because it
didn't fit with your Decor
um you know I
if she's a good gal and she doesn't have
any other of the red flags then I would
you know point it out and not consider
making her the mother of your kids or
even living with her until she dealt
with that problem I don't know if that's
her going to counseling or getting help
or it could be a drug addiction it could
be a smoking addiction it could be an
alcohol addiction like any kind of
addiction some of them are worse than
others obviously
um but again like if you want the best
life possible find a gal that doesn't
have any of these red flags or it's
something simple like extreme jealousy
is one of the red flags on the list a
certain amount of jealousy is good like
you want her to have some competition
anxiety to feel somewhat anxious that
you're out there in the world doing
things where is he what what could he
possibly be doing who is that random
girl 17 feet away from him in the
background that's when it starts pushing
into like weird areas where it's like
you know who is that girl in that
photograph Robert that was 17 feet away
from you giving you like the cut eye in
that photograph that you posted the
other day or that I saw on that media
piece that's when it starts to get weird
into the stranger and that's when you
you know you like that's something that
she has to deal with right yeah her
being a little bit jealous or anxious
about you traveling is fine but if it's
her constantly blowing up your phone
checking in on you randomly calling you
then it becomes problematic and it
becomes difficult for you oh yeah that
totally makes sense I wish we had this
conversation years ago I once dated a
girl
that we had just started dating and she
would look at old like multiple years
old Instagram post of mine so like we
had just met for a couple of months
she's looking at posts that I put out
two three years ago she would see what
girls liked the post
and then she would like be researching
these girls and then asking them I'm
like what in the world yeah all day like
I just got home from work and you've
been sitting here running a private
investigative firm on Instagram very
weird stuff yeah the female mind is
interesting it it operates very very
differently and it and it takes a lot of
pass uh involvements with other women in
it into consideration and like a healthy
woman would see that other women have
have engaged with you and do have desire
for you and just think to yourself okay
this guy's a top shelf man you know
pre-selection obviously other women dig
his Vibe I'm I'm very happy to have him
in my life but it starts to lean into
crazy when they start doing things like
that and then following these random
girls maybe even dming them and and hey
you know you look familiar did we go to
university together just to sort of you
know spark up a conversation and see
where it goes and then the similar you
know connection with Robert Breedlove
sort of pops up in the car it's it's not
that un uncommonly you know when women
like you but there's a little bit of a
crazy unit so that like when it goes
that far yeah yeah yeah well when
they're picking fights like come on
she's picking a fight with me about
something like how is this even a toxic
drama yeah yeah it's a drama queen yeah
exactly uh okay you mentioned this topic
offline this uh notion of genuine
burning desire
um what is that and what how is that
something we should be looking for in
our romantic Partners is this is this a
male to female only or female to male or
is it both ways
um how does that fit into the picture
here
yeah I think it's more important for
male to female although women should
contemplate I mean you know if gals are
watching this that they they should be
dealing with a guy that doesn't really
like them either
um but I think for men it's more
important because women because women's
uh sexual strategy their dating strategy
if you will uh it appears to be their
hypergamous nature and all that means is
that women prefer to date across and up
on the socioeconomic scale right
um they don't like to date down so if
you're I mean they will date down on a
short-term basis like it's it's why a
woman will sleep with a guy that's just
been out of jail covered in tattoos
riding a motorcycle who has nothing to
his name uh or a pot to piss in or a
winner to throw it out of because he's
because he looks like a bad boy right so
that short-term strategy still exists
for them but for the most part women
because they're hyperness they want guys
either at their level or preferably
better than them right so genuine
burning desire is and is an indicator
it's uh you know if you look at the uh
barometer you're going to have an idea
what the weather's like outside so it's
so it's an indicator
um and it's why I I'm I'm constantly you
know referring to only choose women that
choose you right
um and it's not just to choose you but
it's to have genuine desire for you
meaning other men will appear invisible
to her right
um if she has genuine burning desire for
you if you say something like you know
when she comes at you and says Where Do
We Stand I dig your Vibe you know like
the talk again and you say to her yeah
you know that's that's good but I can't
take a woman seriously that post
provocative pictures online okay no
problem I'll just delete my Instagram
that's what a woman with genuine burning
desire will say to you she won't argue
with you she won't she won't call you
insecure she'll absolutely just say here
let's just delete it right now I don't
need it it's you know it's not important
because she sees you as her best option
so
when you invite a woman in your life
especially in the west you've got issues
with family law that can complicate your
life unnecessarily you've got all kinds
of problems that can you know become
evident if she doesn't see you as her
first choice there's a stand-up comic I
can't remember if it was Chris Rock or
Chris Tucker but they said something
along the lines of and stand-up comedy
is great because behind every joke
there's some truth you know and it
obviously which is why people laugh and
he said something along the lines of
ladies the number one reason why you're
pissed off today is because you haven't
you're not married to your first choice
you haven't got your first choice
sitting beside you and the room erupts
in the laughter because it's for the
most part true right like women usually
have to settle when it comes to marriage
they don't often get their first choice
they get their second or third choice or
something like that so again I mean if
you're gonna have kids with a woman why
would you do it with a woman that
doesn't genuinely have burning desire
for you I'll give you a real example
um and I talk about this in my book
um I mentioned how women will break
rules for alpha males
but make them for beta males so I'm
sitting down on the you know this date
with this gal we're you know we're
having a sip on the drink
um she wasn't my style like it was one
of these you know situations where she
ended up being taller and and heavier
than she looked in her photographs but
I'm like you know she's pretty and she's
funny so let's have a drink so we're
sitting down there and she proceeds to
tell me how
um she doesn't get intimate with a guy
until at least eight dates
and I thought to myself okay well I'm
I'm not interested in her anyway so I'm
just going to say what's on my mind
which is just how I operate and I just
said where I go look like I don't
negotiate desire I'm not I don't do the
back and forth thing where there's rules
here and you have to cross the line here
and I have to jump through like that's
not how I roll like I only deal with
genuine intimacy like a woman that
genuinely wants me and it dawned upon me
when she said to me right after that she
was drinking her you know a drink she
put down her drink and she looked me in
her she looked me in my eyes and her
pupils dilated and she got very serious
and mind you I was only sitting at the
table with her for about 15 minutes at
the time like we just got our drinks she
goes fine let's go to the bathroom and
[__] right now and I thought wow that's
that's interesting right so that is a
woman that is like she's testing you to
see where you are whether you're an
alpha male or a beta male when she
realizes where you stand because you're
not going to put up with her [__]
yeah you say you know no then she
immediately resorts to her most powerful
tool which is her sexuality right let's
go to the bathroom and do it right so
that there is genuine burning desire you
know for me at that time I mean I didn't
have it for her I didn't do it I you
know we just wrapped up the date sort of
thing you know 40 minutes later after
the drink but that's a good example of
what that looks like I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out